es una macrooperación internacional la
operación de hunter logró arrestar a 150
sospechosos de comerciar productos
ilegales como drogas duras y armas de
fuego en la conocida como dark web 65
detenciones se dieron en eeuu 47 en
alemania 24 en reino unido- y las demás
en países bajos francia suiza y bulgaria
en
los resultados obtenidos por esta
coalición de 9 países tienen las
banderas aquí en la pantalla son
espectaculares y la mayoría de los
compradores o vendedores arrestados son
considerados por europol como objetivo
de alto valor
más arriba
los agentes incautaron alrededor de 31
millones de dólares en efectivo y
bitcoins así como 234 kilos de drogas y
45 armas aún así la europol sugiere que
hay más por hacer díaz la operación dark
hunter en sí misma ha terminado sin
embargo en todos los estados miembros de
la unión europea todavía hay actividades
en curso los investigadores todavía
están trabajando en la enorme cantidad
de datos que pudimos recopilar del
derribo del mercado oscuro a principios
de este año y de hecho podemos esperar
que se produzcan más arrestos
en enero de este año europol anunció que
había desbaratado un mercado en línea
llamado dark market en el que se vendían
drogas ilegales
la operación fue dirigida por las
agencias policiales alemanas